Sprint one for Orion. ORION-118 is broken into fourteen tickets. I want to walk the list, get estimates, and stop when we hit capacity rather than committing to everything and missing.
What's capacity? We've got two people on this plus Marcus part-time, and I'm on call the second week.
I'm budgeting sixty percent of your time in the on-call week. So call it fourteen effective days across the sprint for you, ten for Lea, and Marcus at four.
Before we estimate, the seats mockups from last week. We picked option B in the design review, the two-number layout with the tooltip. That's now three tickets, not one.
Three because?
The layout, the tooltip content which needs copy review, and the empty state, because a brand new account has zero of both numbers and the two-number layout looks broken when both are zero.
Fine, three tickets. Estimates?
Two days, half a day, one day. The tooltip copy is blocked on Sofia signing off the wording.
The aggregation job is the big one. I've split it into schema migration, the hourly job itself, and backfill. Two, four, and three days.
Backfill is three days of work or three days of waiting?
One day of work and two days of it running. Twelve million rows a day times ninety days of history is a billion source rows. I'd rather run it in chunks over a weekend than lock a table for an hour.
Please run it in chunks. And please run it against the replica first so I can watch what it does to disk.
That's the plan. Replica first, then production over a weekend.
My four days are the cohort rollup and the HLL sketches. The rollup is straightforward. The HLL part I want to timebox, because I've read the extension docs but never run it at this size.
Timebox to what, and what's the fallback if it doesn't work?
Two days. Fallback is exact distinct counts at daily and monthly grain only, computed separately. More storage, more jobs, but no unknowns.
Good. I'll note the fallback on the ticket so nobody has to reconstruct it later.
One thing I want to raise. The API. I was going to build one endpoint per chart, and I've changed my mind. I think we want one query endpoint with a small typed request body.
That's more work for me, not less. Every chart has to construct a query object.
It's more work once and less work per chart after. With one endpoint per chart, chart eleven means a backend deploy. With a query endpoint, chart eleven is frontend only.
I can see that. But I want the request type generated from the backend schema, not hand-written in TypeScript, because those will drift within a month.
Agreed. I'll generate types from the OpenAPI spec as part of the build.
Is that a decision? Because it changes two estimates and I'd like to write it down properly rather than discover it in code review.
Yes. One query endpoint, typed request body, types generated from the spec. Add a day to the API ticket and take half a day off each chart ticket.
Recorded as ORION-204. Where does that leave us on capacity?
I count nine and a half days of my ten, which means I have zero slack, which means the first thing that goes wrong pushes something out.
Then let's cut something now rather than pretending. What's the least valuable thing on your list?
The empty state for the seats layout. It's real, but it only affects accounts in their first hour of existence, and it's a cosmetic problem.
Moved to sprint two. That gives you a day of slack. Daniel, you're at fourteen of fourteen.
The backfill is two of those days and it's unattended. I'm comfortable. If the on-call week is bad, the thing that slips is the backfill, and the backfill slipping hurts nobody.
Agreed, nobody is looking at ninety-day-old charts in a beta.
Then sprint one is committed. Twelve tickets, two moved out. Demo on the fifth of February, which is the same day as the postmortem for MI-412, so I'll find a different slot.
What was MI-412? I saw the channel but I was heads-down.
Connection pool exhaustion on the primary last Thursday. Forty minutes of degraded writes. Not our doing, but it's why I keep asking about what runs on that instance.
Understood. I'll be careful with the backfill.
That's the sprint. I'll update the board this afternoon.